pour moi toutes les questions d'état le
gouvernement du pays où on vit des
différents avis qui existent et la
gauche la droite et tous les autres
côtés mais moi personnellement je n'ai
pas un avis politique très déterminé
longer les opinions mais je me concentre
sur mon avis sur autre chose que la
politique particulièrement sur le
travail c'est moi c'est beau c'est plus
important qu'avant tout savoir des
opinions à partir du moment où on a une
opinion
on fait de la politique qu'on le veuille
ou non je suis pas tellement axé sur sur
un certain parti mais je pique un peu si
je puis dire on certains partis les axes
les actions qu'ils me soient qui me
concerne loup qui me plaisent quoi enfin
vous aimeriez farm et votre propre parti
du congrès n'ont pas mon propre parti
mais enfin je prends un peu ce qui
m'intéresse dans chaque partie quoi
comme il ya souvent quelque chose
d'intéressant
quant à moi la politique
il m'a jamais vraiment intéressé je
m'intéressais dans la mesure que tous on
m'a pas mal de mes amis en parlent en
juge je prends parti à leur conversation
j'écoute mais je ne connais pas assez la
politique ce qui se passe vraiment est
ce que vous cherchez à vous renseigner
oui particulier par l'intermédiaire de
mes parents m'aient failles sont pas
très très choquant je pose des questions
sur la politique je sais même pas très
bien leur position même je sais pas ce
qu'ils pensent qu'à chaque fois que
j'ouvre la bouche sur sa bombe et ne
répondent pas très clairement comment
s'appelle avoir le ministre comment
comment s'appelle le premier ministre
actuellement premier ministre chaban
delmas pour pour moi un intuitif idée à
mon avis n'existe pas enfin rien qui
soit objectif qui essaient de présenter
le problème à des gens qui sont pas
forcément qu'ils n'ont pas forcément des
connaissances donc essayer de se mettre
au niveau de tout le monde quoi parlera
de la mer un petit peu d'aidé mieux et
puis franchement la principale qualité à
avoir c'est d'être objectivement pas
comme c'est pas possible pour un parti
sur générale 6,6 il que c'est vraiment
devant des tas de gens ma première idée
qui va avoir c'est de faire du bliss
thébaux son parti ses opinions quoi donc
c'est un cercle st cercle fermé
ce n'est pas un homme politique actuelle
qui vous séduit particulièrement nos
traditions comment vous informez vous
ben on est informé par un peu tous enfin
c'est peut-être pas tout le temps très
objectif c'est pas moi la télévision la
radio la presse ça coinçait
non moi la politique nous faisons face
est quelque chose de très important
parce que confère la subit on est dans
une société qui est quand même basé sur
la politique
quelle image vous faites vous de l'homme
politique idéal l'homme politique idéal
il y avait un homme dont on parle
beaucoup au petit le mans par exemple
c'est john fitzgerald kennedy
à mon avis ça représente un idéal parce
qu'il est croyant ce qu'ils aient pas
mon avis d'après tout ce qu'on dit et
puis il intéresser les gens à ce qu'il
faisait quand mon avis c'est ça est-ce
que vous parlez de politique avec vos
parents oui ça m'arrive c'est ce qu'ont
partagé leurs opinions
quelquefois quelquefois et quelquefois
évidemment pas la même chose
est ce qui vous arrive de vous leur a
posé les vôtres a bien sûr toute façon
je pense que lorsqu'on fait tant soit
peu de politique on essaye d'imposer ses
idées même à ses parents à même à ses
parents vous y est parvenu plus forte
raison
j'essaye d'y parvenir j'y parviens
peut-être pas toujours j'essaie il est
arrivé d'avoir la victoire à wigan ne
les ai pas en tête mais certaines
j'espère n'est moins faux savoir
quelqu'un de bonne définition de la
contestation
personnellement bon allez vous voulez je
crois que général et des déjà été assez
bonne mais si vous voulez j'ai aussi un
manque de franchise quelquefois qui qui
joue beaucoup
enfin bon ben moi je suis la
concertation je suis d'accord par
exemple on avait au moment de joie de
pression s'était tenu aux partis ou
n'importe quoi on avait dit au revoir
angers ça tout seul bon ben je sais pas
ce que ça redonne n empêche qu on y suit
le brave jeu enfin le ministre des
armées et je crois que la protestation
enfin pour certaines choses c'est utile
et efficace
contestez vous même qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont peut-être cesser la loi debré
c'était une contestation non pas
politique
enfin pour moi sa partie on a voulu
l'amener comme ça mais plutôt par
exemple que le fait que 150 mille quatre
cent mille jeunes aillent dans la rue
c'est pas une contestation politique
c'est une contestation contre quelque
chose contrôle à mon avis le fait qu'on
n'ait pas de liberté et qu'on aimait se
retrouver entre nous le fait qu'ils
aient des tas et des tas de gens qui
sont trouvés pourtant testé ben je crois
que tu as fait d'après des opinions
politiques bon pour l'atteindre c'était
donc de remettre le seuil sanitaire à
18,2 m ca et 6 à 18 ans en sursis à part
pour s'attaquer en médecine bon bah
c'est tout à fait je crois je crois que
on a amplement fait tiquer est pour moi
la protestation à ce moment là a été a
été très efficace du fait que tout que
tout le monde a pu se regrouper à c est
ce que ce n'est pas l'impression que ça
devient un peu un acte motifs on
conteste pour contester sans but
oui sans vous faisiez de retour ici
c'est même devenu une mode c'est comme
une façon de s'habiller c'est quand même
bien évidemment seulement [ __ ] croire
que dans ta jaeghere sommes une minorité
qui croit qu'on bascule
je crois vous avez quel âge j'ai moins
de 16 ans j'aurais 16 ans au moins nous
était arrivé d'aller dans les
manifestations ça m'est déjà arrivée
pourrait faire quoi pour contester aussi
si vous dites à vos parents que vous
contestez vous allez me fais station
qu'est ce qu'ils disent et alors au
début j'étais restée pas très chaud ça
sont que quelques sauts pas comme ça on
y va quand même quoi le fait c'est parce
que vous par environ non on ne va pas
vous va si on a des idées vraiment fixé
ses retombées se font leur hobby la
politique c'est donc en dehors des
parents n'ont pas forcément la faute au
moment où ils comprennent pas ou du
whisky et puis l'art de gouverner et
voilà politique bien c'est la principale
activité de nouveau la politique ça sert
à gouverner un pays
c'est l'économie et de la politique dans
tout ce qu'on fait chaque jour enfin je
parle trop longtemps ou encore et à
l'école qu'un gouvernement comptait pas
une décision fait diplomate
on va refaire de la politique et même
nom à l'école quand on parle des copains
quand il faut pas dire une réflexion
déplacée sa salle duclos match alors je
trouve que on parle un peu trop de la
politique parce que quand on nous parle
quand on allume la télévision le poste
de radio on entend toujours le parti
intel s'est réunie comme monsieur untel
a fait ceci je crois qu'on devrait plus
parler des des choses moins importante
quoi la télé
la politique on en entend parler tout le
temps mais ça veut dire que tu penses
par cette hausse soit 31.6 c'est quand
même important ne faut pas trop en
parler parce que guitar heaven encore
les taux n'ont pas souvent bah moi pour
moi la politique c'est l'expression des
idées de certaines personnes puis pas à
l'école par exemple nous on peut enfin
quand on parle d'un professeur qu'on est
d'accord ou pas pour nous c'est de la
politique
je trouve qu'on entend trop jeune pour
s'occuper de sa femme par un peu sont
intéressés comme ça on peut hein peuvent
écouter la politique enfants un peu trop
jeune encore isabelle quand on sait
qu'en tu entend un homme politique
parler à la télévision la radio induits
par les premiers ministres actuellement
c'est qu'ils vendent ce qu'ils pouvaient
me disent aimer l'idée finances pascal
c'est qui
[Musique]
sauf peut être important mais je dois
dire que ça me convient pas du tout
n'est ce pas fait ça m'intéresse pas du
tout je crois que les femmes combien
sont aussi intéressés parce que c'est là
vidal lte à l'avant les fera aussi je me
rends compte on a vidé l'hectare tu
penses que plus tard tu feras de la
politique non faut pas être bête pour
faire de la politique on pas quoi quand
on est trop honnête on peut faire de la
politique
[Musique]